But I want to take you somewhere and you want to always look into this
when you are working with python. So I'm going to type on W3 schools.
list methods
I will keep this as reference.
But as you can see, we'll remove the only the first instance.
If you want to remove every instance well.
There are different ways you can go about this.
It can either repeat yourself.
Or you know effectively use a for
Loop.
So but that is again.
the least
efficient way of removing the element
one thing to
avoid increasing the time complexity which is what this will do
is to use space complexity.
So instead of going through
the list several times looking for an item
to remove.
You can go through it once.
How to do this what you would do is you would you have your original list
and you want to eliminate all the Nokia's right?
Let's do it here. Okay. So let's
say you have a list of values.
And you have multiple.
Elements with value Nokia and
you want to remove all of these?
Okay.
The first time you use the remove method.
It will get rid of that.
But then you have to run it again to remove the next Nokia.
So your runtime will be your bigger would
be.
two times n
if we had a third one, it will be three times that so very bad.
Something you want to do is increase the space complexity, which means
instead of taking up more time. Take up
more space.
so you can have
a second array called Brands, too.
Initially will be empty. So you will go through the list just
once
and then you will have a simple FNL condition if it's
equal to Nokia ignore.
So you will go to the list once so let's start with
this one apple is a Nokia. No, let's put it here.
Nokia is a Nokia. Yes. So let's ignore it Samsung is
a Nokia. No, let's put it here.
And then we can just ignore that one. So you can go through
the list. Now. You have increased your space complexity. Why
because you have created a second data structure.
Okay. Remember we said that whenever you create something and you
whenever you type something in your program, it will go to temporary storage
and temporary storage.
has
is a lot obviously it's much faster the permanent storage but it's a
lot smaller. So you have to be careful with how you use the space, but nowadays
storage temporary storage is very
cheap.
They are abundant and they are very cheap. So if
you have to choose between time complexity and space
complexity always use space complexity.
So instead of going to list two three times just
create another data structure.
It will take a
you know.
negligible amount of space
And then once you've done this, you can just discard that actually python will
discarded for you.
I hope that makes sense.
Okay, so whenever we have to choose between time and
space always to space.